the movie makeover is you know sort of
the convention has boiled down to the
grill takes off her glasses and she's
hot that's Todd vanderwerff Fox comms
culture editor we got together to talk
about makeover movies you know the ones
given the right look the right boyfriend
BAM in six weeks she's the one being
crowned prom queen for all that it gets
made fun of and justifiably made fun of
I think Rachael Leigh Cook cells to
makeover and she's all that to the
degree that I just like okay sure nobody
noticed that she looked like Rachael
Leigh Cook until now one of the very
first movies with a makeover as its
central plotline was a film called now
Voyager starring Betty Davis Charlotte
played by Davis pretty much had every
single convention you see in makeover
movies today she was shy and nervous she
wore glasses she had a unibrow and after
a brief stint in a sanatorium she came
out looking like a real winner I've lost
over 25 pounds it won't fit it's rooted
in Cinderella it's rooted in any story
of the girl or boy who discovers they're
secretly royalty which is a famous fairy
tale convention me
a princess shut up all right so there
are a few things that always happen in a
makeover movie one you have to establish
that the girl or guy is invisible to the
people around them or clumsy or both
number two you have to find them as
seemingly unattainable love interest
[Music]
number three their friends convince them
that the only way to get out of their
shitty situation is a makeover let's do
a makeover number four the big reveal
[Music]
it's occasionally been gender flipped
and you have the guy like does his hair
a different way and suddenly everybody's
like oh wow what a good-looking guy what
I think is interesting about the
makeover story is that probably in the
last 30 years we don't want it to be
that easy Willis is perfect for this
Sharra's main thrill in life is a
makeover okay it gives her a sense of
control in a world v chaos clueless is
based on the Jane Austen novel Emma as
it really gets at some of her themes at
social class and propriety and what
women are allowed to be and the
character who needs to makeover
basically as Alicia Silverstone's
character she doesn't realize that until
the very end and like in some ways the
audience doesn't as well and it's a
marvelously structured movie like if you
look at it at that level let me just let
me just do a shout out to the recent
movie the Duff how could you guys not
tell me this whole time and I was your
Duff or what your designated ugly fat
friend the Duff really understood that
Mae Whitman's character in that movie
was not gonna put on like a pink prom
dress and suddenly be you know Taylor
Swift she was always gonna be kind of
the quirky funny girl are you wearing
pajamas
oh my god you know I get it Wesley okay
I'm disgusting I'm a I'm a Swamp Thing
I'm a regular Bela Lugosi
makeover was less about becoming someone
who was conventionally attractive to
like dudes and more about becoming the
kind of girl she would be when she was a
junior in college and had sort of
figured her [ __ ] out with some intensive
work she'll be ready for the world's
finest trailer park makeover movies
aren't the most sophisticated stories in
the world but it's a trope that
resonates with people teenagers
constantly want to hear that they're
okay the way they are that's ultimately
what the makeover story's about it's
about that when you put the glasses back
on and the prom dress comes off and
you're dressed in your artsy
paint-spattered overalls you're still
like a worthwhile person
[Music]